the ordinary and the extraordinary exist
side by side here
rows of bodies outside butcher's
mortuary
don't even receive a second glance
people seem desensitized to the death
that's dominated their lives for months
these bodies are just lying out in the
sun waiting to be pulled in for
examination
we don't really know anything about who
these people were
but it's clear from the
very strong smell it's hard to describe
quite how bad it is
that these people have clearly been dead
for some
time
we then learn butcher that's seen some
of the war's worst atrocities has
received these bodies from mario pole
500 miles away
another place in ukraine now synonymous
with the horrors of this war
these just a tiny fraction of the
thousands of people estimated to have
died in the city
were they from the steel plant
yesterday
it's taken more than a month for these
bodies to reach this point after the
azov style steel plant fell in may
they were brought here to help relieve
other mortuaries overwhelmed
we were invited into the post-mortem
examinations
nothing prepared us for what we would
see
the two bodies being examined are
decomposing from head to toe
you can't make out their faces but they
appear to be young men
forensic experts in full protective gear
use wire to track bullet entry and exit
points
while a prosecutor and police collect
evidence
no one wants to speak on camera here
and they don't want any of the bodies
identified
but it's clear these people are under a
lot of pressure
ukraine is struggling to cope with the
number of dead
outside the mortuary we're told this
lorry is holding more bodies that have
been here for three weeks
while a local woman arrives in search of
her dead brother it feels a desperate
last resort
his answer seems to kill her hope of
finding him
out
she tells us he lay dead on his balcony
for three to four days before he was
taken away by the ukrainian army
there's such a wretched in dignity to
all this
a family member desperately seeking her
brother's body
and bodies whose family members
likely have no idea where they lay
sally lockwood sky news butcher